j'adore cette histoire j'adore cette
image j'adore cette idée
la boîte à soleil est là à l'idée de
vous la raconter j'éprouve les mêmes
sensations que celle que je ressentais
quand j'étais enfant et que ma maman me
raconter cette histoire c'est l'histoire
d'une petite fille qui veut offrir un
cadeau à son grand frère pour son
anniversaire et elle a cette idée
magnifique elle décide de lui offrir du
soleil alors elle prend une boîte vous
savez une boîte à coulisse et toute la
journée elle gambade dans jardin avec sa
boîte pour tenter de capturer le moindre
bout de soleil la petite fille est hyper
concentré sur sa capture du soleil elle
est très attentive elle ouvre la boîte
vittel la referme et encore et encore
alors son frère et intrigues et surtout
que elle cache la boîte derrière son dos
mais qu'est ce que tu as donc dans cette
boîte et la petite fille malicieuse lui
répond ah ah
avec ce que j'ai dans cette boîte tu
peux créer et transformé des milliers de
choses mais il faut que tu attendes ce
soir le soir arrive la petite fille
attrape sa boîte et là vous savez quoi
la boîte bris de la lumière jaillit de
tous les interstices
alors elle se précipite dans la chambre
de son frère en brandissant sa boîte à
bout de bras parce que elle a un peu
peur quand même
elle sait bien qu'en réalité c'est pas
trop possible ne vous raconte pas la fin
pas tout de suite en tout cas ce que je
peux déjà vous dire c'est que c'est
important
une boîte à soleil c'est très important
d'avoir une boîte à soleil au fond de
soi je me souviens de mathieu celle ci
c'est une histoire vraie battue à huit
ans je suis psy
je le reçois au cabinet en urgence
mathieu est assis en face de moi
il est effondré il sanglote sans pouvoir
s'arrêter
i look est en fait la veille au soir ils
regardent tranquillement la télé avec
son papa et sa maman
il leur fait un baiser de bonnes nuits
il part se coucher et soudain le matin
c'est le drame absolu
son papa jeune est mort brutalement
d'une rupture d'anévrisme effroyable et
moi enfin ce petit bonhomme noyé dans
ses larmes
je suis complètement désemparé mais
qu'est-ce que je peux faire
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour l'aider
mais à quoi ça me faire d'être psy alors
bien sûr dans mon métier j'ai appris des
tas théorie ok j'ai accumulé des
ribambelles de connaissances
bien sûr j'ai été formé à de multiples
techniques psychothérapeutique
ok ok on m'a théoriquement appris à
soulager la souffrance mais la face à
cet enfant qui pleure si fort et c'est
tellement normal que cet enfant pleure
dans ces circonstances
qu'est-ce que je peux faire qu'est ce
que je peux trouver tout ce que je sais
ne me sert à rien
alors je me tais
je me sente jeu prend une grande
respiration je ferme les yeux
enfin je crois je me souviens plus très
bien et surtout je me relie à ce que je
ressens au plus profond de moi pour
essayer de trouver une idée quelque
chose à lui dire je plonge littéralement
dans mes ressources
j'essaie en tout cas je sais que je peux
pas le consoler il a 8 ans son papa est
mort mais j'aimerais tellement l'apaiser
même un tout petit peu et puis je ré
ouvre les yeux
je plonge mon regard dans le sien et je
m'entends lui dire tu sais au fond de
toi tu as un trésor un immense trésor et
ce trésor
c'est tout l'amour que tu as partagé
avec ton papa c'est tous les moments que
vous avez passé ensemble c'est tous les
baisers tous les cas l'un que vous avez
eu tous les deux et ce trésor tu sais
quoi
la mort ne l'a pas emporté tu l'auras
toujours au fond de toi et tu pourras
aller puiser tout au long de la vie et
aussi dans les moments les plus
difficiles de ton existence et même
quand tu seras grand
c'est ta boîte à soleil pendant quelques
secondes
mathieu me regarde il retient sa
respiration comme s'ils étaient en
suspens puis ses larmes reprennent et on
se tait tous les deux
j'ai revu mathieu il n'y a pas très
longtemps un mathieu presque adulte et
il m'a dit que il se souvenait bien de
ce jour là parce que au milieu de ses
larmes il avait ressenti quelque chose
de chaud et que ça l'avait profondément
marqué et qu'il s'en était toujours
souvenu et qu'elle avait beaucoup aidé
c'est pour ça que c'est si important
d'avoir une boîte à soleil et d'avoir
cette intention de la remplir à chaque
instant de sa vie
tout le monde peut capturer du soleil
tout peut apprendre à capturer ces micro
moments de vie qui sont doux qui sont
agréables qui nous font chaud au coeur
mais auquel il faut être très attentif
parce que ils sont tellement éphémère
souvent on passe à côté on les voit pas
on est saisi pas
et pour graver ses petits bonheurs
eh bien il faut faire très attention
parce que on passe beaucoup de notre
temps
beaucoup de notre vie à attendre
attendre quoi le bonheur ou à courir
après lui ce bonheur avec un grand b ce
bonheur majuscule vous savez celui qui
viendra après quand on aura plus
d'argent quand on aura une maison quand
on aura des enfants ou quand les enfants
seront grands quand on sera en couple ou
quand on sera séparé c'est selon comme
si un jour le bonheur arrivé en me
disant bonjour je suis de bonne heure je
crois que l'on attendait depuis
longtemps
non ça ne marche pas comme ça ça ne
marche pas comme ça le bonheur
ce sont les petits bonheurs les petits
bbb minuscule les bonheurs ordinaires
qui font qu'ils fabriquent le bonheur
extra ordinaire c'est comme ça c'est
tout et pour graver en soit ces petits
bonheurs la seule chose dont nous ayons
besoin c'est de notre corps et ça tombe
bien parce qu'il est tout le temps avec
nous le bonheur ça s'attrape en
ressentant en ressentant vraiment le
bonheur ça se sent
hop je m'arrête un instant je me relie à
moi aux émotions qui sont là et je les
encres au plus profond de mon corps je
vis un moment agréable n'importe lequel
hop je le sens je le grave je suis avec
quelqu'un que j'aime hop je le mets dans
ma boîte avec tout le bonheur que je
ressens ou encore enfin ça fait mon truc
vous savez les gouttes de pluie sur les
vitres sont les trains roulent surtout
très vite ça fait comme des feux
d'artifice j'adore ça je peux regarder
pendant des heures et hop je capture ce
moment pour le mettre dans ma boîte je
mange quelque chose dont je raffole
en ce moment c'est les cerises plutôt
que de les engloutir je ralentis je
prends mon temps et hop
tiens et la fille si on faisait une
expérience tous ensemble vous êtes
d'accord
s'ils ont ramené tous notre attention
sur nos sensations
celle qu'on peut sentir juste là
peut-être la sensation de ma posture de
mon corps assis ou debout
peut-être que je peux juste un peu bougé
pour pour mieux le sentir et puis
tranquillement et si j'en ai envie
seulement si j'en ai envie
je peux fermer les yeux
alors moi je vais fermer les yeux donc
vais vous perdre de vue et maintenant je
vois si je peux focaliser mon attention
sur les points de contact de mon corps
peut-être sur le lot de mes cuisses ou
de mes fesses sur le siège ou peut-être
le dos appuyé contre le dossier ou sur
mes pieds la pression de mes pieds sur
le sol
tout ce que je peux sentir
je ramène mon attention comme si je
refermer les volets de ma maison
non pas pour être coupée du monde mais
au contraire pour être mieux relier à
moi même et aux autres
qu'est ce que je peux sentir
qu'est ce que je peux sentir dans mon
corps est-ce que je peux sentir que je
suis là vraiment là souvent on le sait
qu'on est là mais dans notre tête on est
ailleurs souvent très loin pas vraiment
là et là juste là juste manon
est-ce que je peux me relier entrer en
contact avec mes sensations
mes sensations sont agréables je le sens
je le sens vraiment hop je peux les
mettre dans ma boîte à soleil ou pas
c'est comme ça une boîte à soleil être
attentif vraiment présent avec tout son
corps avec tous ses sens à ce qu'on vit
et puis pour ceux qui les ont fermé je
peux doucement rire ouvrir les yeux
mais qu'est ce qui se passe dans notre
cerveau quand on fait ça quand on est
totalement relié à ce qu'on est en train
de vivre
et ça c'est les neurosciences qui le
disent et bien notre cerveau déclenché
la sécrétion de tout un cocktail
d'hormones qui nous font du bien qui
nous apaise les ocytocine les
endorphines
et du coup ce moment vécu va venir
enrichir notre boîte à soleil notre
trésor parce que bien sûr la boîte à
soleil n'empêche n'empêche pas les
malheurs de l'existence elle peut pas
permettre d'éviter les souffrances mais
elle permet de les amortir
elle permet d'avoir des ressources pour
aller y puiser pour ne pas être vidés au
sens propre pour ne pas se faire
engloutir
et si c'était ça le chemin pour vivre
mieux et c'était vraiment celle là la
psychologie d'aujourd'hui c'est une
vraie bascule on passe de l'archéologie
de la souffrance à la psychologie des
ressources une psychologie qu'on
pourrait appeler préventive celle qui
nous donne des clés pour nos vies celle
qui finalement nous apprend comment
nourrir et cultiver les champs fertiles
plutôt que de s'épuiser à tenter
d'arracher les mauvaises herbes
parce que ce qui est hallucinant c'est
que on continue à fonctionner comme à la
préhistoire notre cerveau est resté
génétiquement programmées comme les
hommes des cavernes notre hamida cette
petite zone qui est nichée au fin fond
de notre cerveau archaïque et dont la
fonction est de décoder les émotions se
déclenche tout le temps face à ce qui
est perçu comme une menace comme un
danger comme si notre survie en dépend
des est alors des milliers
années après on continue de vivre en
état d' alerte permanent on est
polarisée sur ce qui ne va pas c'est ce
qu'on voit en premier convoi en grand
c'est ce qui attire immédiatement notre
attention c'est pour cela qu'il est
tellement important urgent d'apprendre à
modifier le câblage la programmation
c'est pour ça qu'il faut s'entraîner et
la bonne nouvelle c'est que notre
cerveau et plastiques malléable ça
s'appelle la neuroplasticité et grâce à
la capture des petits b on va
restructurer notre cerveau on va créer
de nouvelles connexions on va tracer de
nouveaux chemins et c'est ça qui change
tout entraîné notre cerveau à se
focaliser automatiquement sur ce qui va
bien et comme ça on remplit notre boîte
à soleil presque sans y penser
oui vous vous souvenez vous vous
souvenez dans l'histoire de la petite
fille que le soir venu la boîte à soleil
briller et vous savez pourquoi elle
avait attrapé un ver luisant
génial non déjà elle avait pris un
plaisir fou à courir toute la journée
avec sa boîte et en plus elle a vraiment
attraper un bout de soleil
quelquefois dans la vie aussi c'est
comme ça on croit que ce n'est pas
possible
et pourtant merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]